it's fun you won't find a single  position in the country  well one according experts are 1.7 of  the population is born with intersex  trade pause a second  let's analyze his googling techniques  a two-click google search it's almost as  if he had the whole thing planned out  poorly 1.7 of the population is born  with intersex traits that's from  amnesty.org i mean  yeah i mean i can just like keep keep i  can go down it's from amnesty. i mean  it's from there's there's wikipedia  there's there's please i'm just in  wikipedia okay there's uh here's a  pubmed ncbi um and like this is a  medical journal  anyone that pulled it up from it  you just brought up pubmed and it didn't  reflect what you just reflected so  abstract  0.0018 almost 100 times lower than fosso  sterling estimate of 1.7